and in 1925 physicists said that our
vision of a universe split into an
invisible energy realm and a material
Physical Realm was a total illusion that
everything is energy a whole thing there
is no matter in this world we have been
led to believe that the universe is a
great machine when in fact it is more a
great thought and the reality about that
was quantum physicists have established
since 1925 that Consciousness is the
primary mechanism of creativity of the
world that we experience the universe is
immaterial it's mental and spiritual
live and enjoy and this is so exciting
because science is coming out saying
it's mental and spiritual it's like oh
my God but that's the quantum physics
part and the reality about it why is
that and so important as uh sad Vijaya
just mentioned it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now I say not only is the spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize I'm having a
thought well then the truth is simple as
Richard con Henry said you are creating
this world with your mental activity and
your spirituality combined and then all
of a sudden it says well then if I'm
creating the world then my original
belief that when things didn't go right
I was a victim the universe wasn't
supporting me you know it's like oh I
try so hard and the universe is not
giving me things it turns 180 degrees
around and it basically says this
we are creating this world
and then I say your mind is creating
this world so I listen to this clip
and
I didn't know where to take it
normally when I do these espresso Clips
I've got my own set of thinking my own
ideas my own kind of thought process I
want to add on to it some things are
really easy some things I've talked
about before and I struggle with okay
what's that what's a new story I can
tell so I'm not telling the same stories
over and over and over again
but there was just something about this
one that
maybe I'm not as familiar with Bruce
lipton's world or work
um
nothing immediately came to mind
and as I sat here in the car with my
dogs
trying to think of what to say I
realized you know what the best thing to
say is just to be honest and say I don't
know what to say
and then the next thought that came to
mind was I should do an interview with
Bruce Lipton
and it's funny the way the mind works
like that you know I think when
great ideas come to you
first off when ideas come to you
think of them as great ideas that
they're given to you that they're for
you that you can create those things a
lot of times we come up with ideas and
immediately reject them so my first
thought was I don't know what I'm going
to say about this video
so that led to me sharing I don't know
what I'm going to say about this video
and then my second thought was I should
have Bruce Lipton on for us to talk
about it which immediately caused me
some heart palpitations because
I'm always afraid of delivering a bad
interview I'm always scared that it's
not going to be good and especially when
it's somebody outside my field
and I don't have Clarity on it
I I struggle with the interview and the
preparation because I I don't want to
ask questions you know if I'm doing an
interview with somebody I know and I
know they work deeply and we can have
fun and have some great stories I kind
of know where to take it I never know
what their answer is going to be I'm
always asking questions I'm genuinely
curious about not ones that that I know
they have a stage dancer for but I don't
even know what Bruce wearer would lead
off
serious
that I didn't I don't know how to
articulate myself enough to get a good
question out that it's a fruitful
conversation and that fear cannot be a
good enough reason and so
my takeaway from this is I I'm gonna go
and try to get a hold of Bruce Lipton
and do some kind of interview for my
channel and then hopefully he says yes
and then I'm gonna have to figure out
what I'm gonna ask him and hopefully not
completely embarrass myself in the
interview
so this is a slightly different take on
an espresso but I think
I think showing that side is helpful so
the two lessons for me are you know one
when you when you're struggling show it
when you don't know what to say show
that for a lot of people who are
struggling to make content out there
and you're struggling on your first
episode
sure I'm struggling I don't know what
I'm doing I'm getting started here's
here's my mission here's here's what I'm
trying to figure out and share your
thought process if you don't know what
to share
or you don't have a solid opinion share
your thought process share your thinking
share that you're frustrated if you're
if you're struggling that you're
struggling if you're overwhelmed show me
that you're overwhelmed
honestly sometimes those are the best
posts because it shows that you're human
you know it doesn't detract from you
being an expert at what you're you're
great at
and then the second thing is the ideas
that come to you are great trust them
trust those great ideas the fact that my
my first instinct was uh I should do an
interview with him
now I I need to commit to doing it and
take immediate action on it so my as
soon as I stop pressing record on this
I'm going to message Beau who does all
my bookings is awesome he has his own
business if anybody needs uh bookings
for for guests for their shows let me
know and we can intro you the bow I'm
gonna say Bo how do we get Bruce Lipton
on our Channel
for an interview
I don't know what I don't even know
we're gonna talk about yet but I'll
figure it out let's get them on
so different espresso I'd love to know
your thoughts I love your take either
your take on on what he said and you can
explain it to me uh or you're taking
what I said give me some feedback put it
down the comments below
we could be essentially unconscious
which most people are
and our lives look exactly the same why
because once you learn how to get
dressed you know how to get dressed once
you know how to drive a car you don't
have to be conscious how to drive a car
you already got the program so
everything that we learned in our
subconscious mind becomes automatic
Behavior meaning it frees up the
Consciousness so the Consciousness
doesn't have to be dealing with all the
tasks well when you free up the
Consciousness then you have time for
creative thinking
but here's the issue and this is the
catch
when the Consciousness is not focusing
on some job or some task and let's say
it's on a daydream mode it's thinking
about your vacation next week you're
going on vacation and you're thinking
about the plans of your vacation in your
conscious mind
well if your conscious mind is thinking
about the vacation who's running the
day-to-day moment-to-moment life the
answer is the subconscious but now
here's the catch
does the conscious mind observe the
behavior as it automatically plays from
the subconscious mind and I go back and
say well where was your mind I was
thinking about the future well if it's
thinking about the future then it wasn't
paying attention right and the answer is
aha
the nature of the trade-off is the
subconscious mind can run everything
when the conscious mind is busy
if the conscious mind is busy that's not
paying attention and so when it's not
paying attention it does not see the
programs that are playing the
subconscious mind
so to give you like an amusing antidote
about it is you know somebody and you
know their parent and you realize that
this person and a parent pretty much
have the same behavior and so you in
enthusiasm you burst on the scene you
say you know Mary you're just like your
mom
as soon as you say that to Mary back
away from Mary why because she's not
going to take this in welcoming news for
her she's going to say like how can you
say that to her she's not like her mom
at all
and the issue is interesting he's like
the joke is everybody can everybody else
can see that Mary's like her mom but
Mary can't why not the answer is because
when she's playing the programs which
she got from her mother which are in her
subconscious she's playing them because
she's not paying attention and so when
they play she doesn't see them so she's
surprised when people say that she
behaves like her mom even though that's
what her life is all about
now the the conclusion of why all this
dialogue and why was it all important
the answer is this
that we do not see the subconscious when
it plays the subconscious has programs
in it that we primarily got from other
people in our development and the
significance about that is that if we
are operating from this subconscious
mind or not seeing it then we're also
not seeing that we're playing programs
that may not be in any way supporting
who we are and what we want the programs
those are in the conscious mind
so the idea is when life doesn't work
when you don't find that relationship
that your positive thinking was looking
for when you don't get that Health that
you were looking for because your
positive thinking was asking for it we
have a tendency therefore to blame the
outside world because as far as I know
my intention was for all these wonderful
things and when I don't get it it can't
be me because I have all these wonderful
positive intentions
what we didn't see was while we were
having those positive intentions using
our conscious mind for those positive
intentions the subconscious was running
the show
and we didn't see that we generally
sabotage
and destroy or limit our own lives with
behaviors that are not supporting us
and why this is important is because
then we all generally cop the attitude
that there are forces outside of me that
control my life and I am a victim of
this world and I can't do anything about
it as a victim
and as soon as you buy that
you are a victim
and the only problem was it was your own
subconscious programming that that led
to the life that you have and that if
you can understand that and then try to
work with it then you can change your
subconscious programming and change your
manifest as reality and in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material Physical Realm was
a total illusion that everything is
energy the whole thing there is no
matter in this world and to summarize
what the meaning was of famous
physicists in 1930 by the name of Sir
James jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine when in fact it is more a great
thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that Consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal Nature which is
like a a scientific mainstream Journal
was an article by a Quantum physicist at
Johns Hopkins University by the name of
Richard con Henry and his article was
entitled the mental universe
I I know the last two lines in the
article because they were like so
powerful and here's what the conclusion
of the article was
the universe is immaterial it's mental
and spiritual live and enjoy and this is
so exciting because science is coming
out saying it mental and spiritual is
like oh my God but that's the quantum
physics part and the reality about it
why is that so important as uh Assad
Vijaya just mentioned it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
can say that's a spiritual thing and now
I say not only is it spiritual now it is
fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize I'm having a
thought well then the truth is simple as
Richard con Henry said you are creating
this world with your mental activity and
your spirituality combined and then all
of a sudden it says well then if I'm
creating the world then my original
belief that when things didn't go right
I was a victim the universe wasn't
supporting me you know it's like oh I
try so hard and the universe is not
giving me things it turns 180 degrees
around and it basically says this
we are creating this world
and then I say your mind is creating
this world I was looking for
relationships I kept failing at him okay
I end up in the Caribbean teaching at a
medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the Caribbean and hang out I
have a villa on the beach and I got my
own place and uh blah blah blah and I
still wasn't able to find anybody but I
kept looking because I said I need a
relationship I need a relationship so I
meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know I've got a
future that's like she's doing what she
wants and I thought well if you're not
doing anything why don't you uh you want
to come and stay with me and my Villa on
this beautiful Island
he looked at me and she looked at me and
then she said I can't be with you and I
sort of like stop for a moment and she
looked at me and she says you're too
needy
it hit me I said oh my God what am I
looking for a relationship why because
you're not happy so if you're looking
for a relationship because you're not
happy then you're depending on that
relationship to make you happy so that's
not a nice relationship it's
codependency if I give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes and after
she said that I was stunned for a moment
I can't be with you you're too needy she
said and I was and then all of a sudden
I said Thank you thank you very much it
was sort of a slap in the face right the
blessing in disguise right it totally
was it was like wake up and I walked
away from that and I looked at my life
and said you got this most amazing job
you teach a couple days a week you live
in the Caribbean you've got a villa you
got money in your pocket because you get
paid and there's nothing to buy in the
Caribbean anyways I got I say you're
healthy you got money you got a great
place to live you have the most
wonderful job I go you can't be happy
with that that's what I said to myself
I said how can I you know I'm looking
for this person to make me happy I said
oh no first I make me happy yeah and
then when I make me happy
that changed and it did what happened is
I stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you yeah I
love where I live do you love Lucia oh I
love the sea you like it oh I love my
job and all of a sudden I started
focusing on hey these are things I love
and guess what
I didn't need anybody
that's when you created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right 100 because once I didn't need
them I wasn't like yeah come here I was
like yes I don't care how it works they
showed up because I did not need that
was the word because need puts pressure
on that other person that they have to
provide and then they didn't have to
provide it was like hey let me hang out
with you I don't have to provide
anything I could just be me I go yeah
you'll be you I'd be me we have a great
time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until I was happy with myself and until
that happened once I was happy with
myself and I didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away I was cloning stem
cells back in 1967. 40 years ago and the
significant against was while I was
doing this research I was also teaching
medical students so I was teaching
medical students the foundation of how
cells work the conventional story out of
the textbook genes control life what we
call the genetic determinism the belief
that genes control your traits Behavior
your physical characteristics Etc and
what my research revealed when I was
studying the stem cells was this very
profound I put one stem cell in a Petri
dish all by itself and it would divide
every 10 to 12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16
cells 32 cells after about two weeks I
have thousands of cells in the petri
dish but what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then I did the
experiment the experiment was to take
some cells out of the dish and put them
into a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it so I take
the cells out of my stem cell dish put
them in a separate dish with a different
environment and the cells form muscle
but then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there I was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone I say
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so I started to
really say oh my goodness here I am
teaching genes control life to the
medical students and yet the cells were
revealing to me that hey they all had
the same genes but it was environment
that I put them in and so the
environment controlled their life and a
very simple experiment that is very
profound for us today is if I took my
dish with plastic petri dish with cells
in it and moved it from a healthy
environment to a less than healthy
environment the cells get sick and if I
were a doctor of cells I you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again the science that
says there are two minds that are
operating at the same time one is called
the conscious mind and one is called the
subconscious mind I say What's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I said what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are the things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing
psychologists will tell us 70 percent or
more of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people well how do
you change the subconscious mind say how
did it learn in the first place
I say what was the first one I say Theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than Consciousness you have to
slow down the brain to a much slower
vibration then it goes into the
subconscious mind that's why um
hypnotherapists in the old days they had
a watch and they would swing it back and
forth so the watch would swing and they
would tell the person you're getting
sleepy you're getting tired and the
reason they say that is because that
shuts down the conscious vibration and
the next vibration is Theta which is
hypnosis so to get you into hypnosis
first I have to get your conscious brain
to stop
and then in hypnosis State Theta the
vibration Theta then whatever is coming
from the outside is not going into my
conscious mind whatever I see on the
outside is going into my subconscious
program so if you want to change the
subconscious you have to talk to the
subconscious they go how you do that
well number one hypnosis and I go oh
well I need to see the hypnotherapist I
go no this is the cool part I say why I
said we have different vibrations the
lowest vibrations Delta is sleep the
next higher vibration is Theta hypnosis
imagination the next higher vibration is
Alpha calm Consciousness and the next
higher vibration is called beta which is
like School room like what we're doing
here Consciousness okay I go so why is
it rub I said when you're asleep you're
at the lowest and when you start to wake
up you go up first to Theta and that's
like in the morning where you're half
awake and half asleep and and then I say
but then when you're awake you're an
alpha now you're in Consciousness and
then when you go to work you're in beta
which is like the work in Consciousness
but when you come home it reverses so I
come home from work I'm in beta but I
relax oh the Consciousness vibration
slows down the alpha and here's the fact
the moment that the vibrations get a
little lower than Alpha Consciousness is
now shut off for the night you're
sleeping yeah but there's a period of
time after Alpha shuts off before it
reaches Delta the lowest one there's a
period of time of theta I go why is it
relevant I said you put earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want a self-help
program of how to make a relationship be
healthy and do a job whatever you get
the program self-help program I say you
put it on on a CD player let's say and
you put the earphones on and while
you're still awake just before you go to
sleep you can hear what's going on but
the moment you fall asleep conscious
mind shut off but guess what Theta is on
the work is getting done right right
you're getting a self-hypnosis with the
earphone so whatever the you didn't hear
it you were sleeping the subconscious
mind was hearing it and when you repeat
that that's how you put a new program in
so that's number one self-hypnosis I had
tenure I had tenure at the University I
walked out of the university and said
look I I can't keep my integrity and at
the same time teach something I know was
patently wrong so I walked out because I
saw that teaching the belief that genes
control life was very very Incorrect and
it's very interesting because I did that
in 1970 now that's like 30 40 years ago
when we look at our lives and I tell you
that 95 of your life is coming from the
subconscious program
this is not it's new on a scientific
awareness of how this mechanism works
but what's interesting is for 400 years
the knowledge that you could program
somebody and control their lives has
been available it was the Jesuits who
400 years ago said give me a child until
it's seven and I will show you the man
most people didn't understand what they
were saying and what it is is the first
seven years which we now know
biologically and scientifically is the
program period they knew that 400 years
ago and they said if I can get that
program in in the first seven years that
program will determine the life of that
individual I'll show you the man because
they will represent the program
now the really important part is since
every one of us has been programmed the
the big issue is so what were those
programs because if I ask you so what
what program did you get when you were
one year old
I have no idea I wasn't really there and
in fact you were actually being
programmed even before you were born the
last trimester of pregnancy you were
being programmed and I go well this is
really a critical issue because the
first thing I'm telling you is your life
is 95 program uh and most of that is is
really disempowering and of course the
first thing I would think is and what
are those programs so I could deal with
them so I want to make something very
easy for you so you don't have to go and
review your whole life and try to figure
out what the programs are save you a lot
of time
the fact is this you are playing the
program 95 of the day meaning your life
is a printout of your program so you
don't have to go back in time to review
that would just actually irritate the
system more because every time you
review those things that unsettled you
when when you were younger it just
reinforces that same pain that you had
earlier so going back uh and finding out
who did what to who uh is more than just
a waste of time it actually will set you
back a matter of fact there's an an old
phrase that people have heard and it
says Don't Kill the Messenger over the
message
what that means is this don't go back
and blame all the people that did this
and that and that and that that's
irrelevant who they are is irrelevant
what's relevant is what program did you
walk away with not who did the event but
what you learned so now I said okay I've
been programmed and I have no idea what
the program and I said then look at your
life and here's the simple resolution
everything in your life that you like
and it comes to you is because you have
a program to support that that's
wonderful that means that's great it's
going to come to you because that
program is bringing it to you but in
contrast this is the one that's
important
anything you work hard to accomplish
anything you struggle over to make it
happen anything you put a lot of effort
in I want this I'm going to work like
crazy I'm gonna get this my first
question is why are you working so hard
and the answer is very simple
anything you're struggling to try to
accomplish whether it's health or love
relationships whatever it is
if you're struggling it represents a
simple fact your subconscious
programming doesn't support that
conclusion
so the fact is what are my programs look
at your struggle and wherever you're
struggling the struggle is not because
the universe won't provide for you the
struggle is an internal job the struggle
is you're trying to overcome previous
programming that prevents you to go to
that destination so the wonderful part
about this understanding is you don't
have to to review your life you can look
right now at this one moment just look
in your head and say what are the things
that I keep trying to get and they they
seem to be elusive I can't get them
they're always Out Of Reach I say their
their universe is not holding back
it's your own invisible subconscious
behavior when you're putting in a wish
and a desire put it in as if you already
have it
I am healthy I am a good relationship
person I you know I have a great job
what's that I say it's like I already
have it and yet most people don't have
it so they'll say I want a great job I
want a great relationship I want to be
healthy and I go make a recording of
those words we just said that I want to
be healthy today right now Tuesday we're
going to make a recording I say now come
back in one year and let's push the
button on that recording and we come
back a year later and it says I want to
be healthy I go it's a whole year and
you still want to be honest still don't
have it right you didn't say I am
healthy while you're emphasizing I have
a desire to be healthy I want to be
healthy I have a desire to be health and
I go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy you say I
am healthy but then you're looking to
say yeah but in reality I'm sick and I
go no no the function of the mind is to
take the program and turn it into
reality so if I am sick but I put a
program in I am healthy the Mind looks
you know like well wait a second the
program is I am healthy but the body is
not healthy so what's the function of
the Mind
create Health in the body it doesn't
change the program it changes the body
and so the idea is this every time we
put a program in it has to be as if you
already have it and it's by the fact you
could be dying of cancer I go I am
healthy it sounds kind of weird and I go
don't worry about it just put it on I am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up I'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this that whatever
you're downloading you have to say it is
if you already have it because if you
put a future tense on it I will I want I
say if you record that that means you
will always will you know want to have
it you know I will do this you won't get
there so I just want to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't yo ho ho and a bottle of from the
dead man's on the la la la la la la la
la
oh wow what a glorious day to be sailing
on the sea
I think I should be checking my bearings
at this point
North by Northwest that's that's right
Hank told me take a left at the island
then follow North by Northwest and until
I go towards the sunset but it should be
here somewhere Long Island should be
somewhere about
it's not here
I think I better check my calculations
again
so I left Port Moresby at 12 and going
at eight knots by 12 35 we should have
been over here to the left of the island
and then we followed the tangent of the
cosine of 381 for eight minutes to the
right and then we should be approaching
toward Kong Island
[Music]
uh uh
uh oh
I'm lost at sea
what should I do now
I knew I should have trusted my feelings
when Hank gave me directions it just
didn't even feel right and in today's
world we're told don't go by the
feelings if I did I would have probably
been better off at this moment so when
we recognize we have to make a decision
we can do it in two fundamental ways
first do an assessment an analysis of
step by step what does this decision
mean and why should I choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that ask your heart
and the reason why is this the heart
doesn't care about the individual steps
in the decision the heart only looks at
the conclusion either you get more
energy from this decision a good vibe a
feeling that this is right or the heart
will give you a feeling of bad vibes
less energy a feeling that maybe this
isn't the right answer so the
significance is really profound because
the heart just reads energy and higher
energy is more life less energy is less
life so in making a decision yes it's
acceptable to do the analysis but before
you come to that final decision please
check in with your heart feel the
feelings if the feelings are good that
means go toward that direction but if
you feel questioned about it you feel
weaker about it doesn't just feel right
the heart is telling you right off that
that energy is not good for you and you
should use some other decision oh wow
that's so wonderful what a wonderful way
to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better life
[Music]
uh oh
I guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer and simulation
[Music]
Scotty how many times have I told you
not to leave me often see you know I
can't swim
meet me at the bridge you have some
explaining to do I don't care how much
knowledge is in your head if that
knowledge doesn't go into your
subconscious your life will stay exactly
the same as it was you can be the
brightest smartest academic and I say
fine did it change your life and the
answer is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming and when you do
that you are all-powerful in the
creation of your own life and so just
walking around and being able to recite
all these wonderful sayings and things
that you hear from all the wonderful
teachers that we have and you say oh yes
I remember that that's a good quote
that's a nice quote Oh that's a
wonderful saying
it's irrelevant
until that saying becomes part of your
program because now you are living from
the saying and not talking about the
saying and that was the total
transformation of a life that on an
academic level was successful on a
personal level I don't even want to talk
about that uh but it changed everything
why
because instead of having to chase
afterlife
after this understanding things came to
me the light will bring it to you the
only thing that's in your way of the
light is a block in your belief that
other people have put into your
programming you take your knowledge that
you have make it your subconscious
program and you will manifest all of the
wonderful spiritual wisdom that you have
heard throughout your whole life is not
words now
it is life and behavior and that's our
destination itself the thinking is not
that much in our control the brain is
operating as I said 95 from the
subconscious uh but but how did you
actually then get results in a
relatively short space of time well the
first thing how does a subconscious
learn and that's a very critical thing
uh the conscious mind can learn from
reading a book so you the subconscious
mind can read a self-help book and you
go wow that sounds really great and then
you find you read the book but your life
is still the same and this turns out why
and the answer is because the
subconscious mind is more of a habit
mind things that you repeat over and
over again so the reality is if you can
stay conscious
be present and when those negative
thoughts come in our head and
psychologists tell us 70 of the time the
thoughts that are going through our head
are negative and redundant so the same
negative thoughts are going through if
you could stop those thoughts if you
could hear them as they come through
like oh that's not going to work oh this
will never happen those kind of thoughts
if you can hear them and stop them
consciously say no uh change the belief
right there just give the more positive
thing as you repeat this more frequently
and you keep repeating it the
subconscious mind begins to learn so as
a habit if you stay conscious and you
have to work at it and here's why people
say well how come only five percent from
conscious mind 95 from subconscious
because a conscious mind can think into
the future and think into the past and
solve problems then think about it
yourself most of the time you're
thinking about something well if you're
thinking you're using the conscious mind
well if you're using a conscious mind
for thinking then who's running the show
and the answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
I'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is wrong so Jesus told his
followers all the Miracles that I can do
you can do them but even better than I
can and you don't believe it and that
was the whole damn thing in a nutshell
if you don't believe it you can't do it
and I said well where's belief come from
mind I say and then what have you been
programmed you can't do and I said then
you'll never be able to do it
and this is the problem and I and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know that what you
said was true the evenings just say I
feel amazing I feel amazing to repeat
that the mind will will all of a sudden
change how you feel that's that's how it
doesn't Okay so I say number one
self-hypnosis number two after age seven
you still learn how to do new things
that become habits like you didn't learn
how to drive a car until until later
than seven but once you know how to
drive a car remember the first day you
got in it was like oh my God looking out
the windows checking the mirror watching
the gauges keeping your feet on the
pedals just correctly you know looking
paying all these attentions like and I
say today you've been driving for a
while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am I going to do when I get to the
store you're not even thinking about
driving why it's a habit okay I say well
how'd you get that habit because you're
older than seven how'd you get it I said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
I'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and I say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way of the
subconscious learns repeating something
over and over and over again because
that's called habituation making a habit
and I love it the new age today thing is
fake it till you make it I go what the
hell is that I said you're not happy
yeah most of us have trouble being happy
and I said well what if every day all
day long then you can remember you say I
am happy in spite of the fact of what
the hell is going on you just say I am
happy I am happy I am happy I go why
what's going on I say repetition and
it'll be a point where you'll repeat it
to the degree that the subconscious
which learns by repetition will put in I
am happy I said then what's the
consequence I said what's the function
of the Mind take that program and
manifest it now that it's in there I am
happy I wake up one morning guess what I
don't have to say I'm happy it's
automatic I'm already happy all day long
my program said that 95 is coming from
that habituation
you know repetition of the exact thing
you want not Future Vision as if you
have it now we'll put it in a program so
that's first seven years hypnosis after
seven years uh repetition habituation is
how you change it uh a sticky note
people put that stuff on a mirror or
someplace and they go oh yeah those
sticking out and I go that is not
repetition that's a suggestion a
repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving a car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real okay so the first two
things are uh hypnosis second thing is
repetition and thirdly the most you know
effective is called Energy psychology
and I go what's energy psychology it's
called super learning you know so what
the hell is super learning I go maybe
you've seen somebody read a book
by picking up a book and just moving
their finger down the page just like
that just as fast as that
and guess what the subconscious mind the
super computer that it is has read every
word just by moving your finger down
around is read every word on that page
and a person using this super learning
technique and going to a bookstore open
up a book and five minutes later by
thumbing through each page Turn the Page
Turn the Page Turn the Page they can
read a whole book in five minutes that's
super learning I say if you can engage
that function
you can also use super learning to
create new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes it's like I go absolutely and
it's so important why because uh there's
an old phrase that's really critical
it's called necessity is the mother of
invention and I say what's happening
we're facing a mass extinction due to
human behavior that is compromising the
Web of Life humans are creating this
through our Behavior our culture I say
you want to survive this episode this
whole you know Extinction event well
then you have to create something
different you have to change Behavior I
was a scientist and as a scientist we
don't bring spirituality and mind into
the story it's all genes and cells and
molecules and all that and my research
uh on on stem cells uh revealed that
while I was teaching in medical school
that genes control life
my research revealed that it was the
environment in which the cells lived
that control the cells it was outside
information coming into the cells and I
remember how specifically in a moment of
time that I was working on trying to
understand the mechanics from a
molecular point of view how does an
environmental signal control biology and
I was working not on the genes I was
working on the skin of the cell the
membrane and it was it was so profound
it's hard for me to even describe it I'm
working on the understanding how does
information from the environment control
biology and I had looked at the membrane
for years and I wrote a new definition
of the mechanism of the membrane
and I wrote this definition and this is
in 1985. it was about 2 A.M and I wrote
down the membrane is a liquid Crystal
semiconductor with Gates and channels
when I wrote that down there was a pause
and I said I I just I read something
exactly like that and right next to my
first computer Macintosh was a book from
a simple book of understanding your
microprocessor and I opened it up and I
said somewhere and I open it right in
the introduction it said a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with Gates
and channels and I thought oh what a
coincidence they have the same
definition
and then in a couple of seconds I
started to say wait a minute one for one
the parts are exactly the same I said oh
oh my God the membrane is a computer
chip
and on the surface of the cellar like
Keys like on a typewriter and and I
started to realize oh my goodness the
environment is typing on the surface of
the cell information that went into the
cell and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
real exciting and I'm typing on my own
computer typing this information in and
then I realized I am outside of the
computer typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then I said oh my God
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells has a number of keys that
represent a PIN number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same keys on that each of us
have a different pin number to get into
our own cells it's our personal identity
and these are the keys and I realized oh
my god well we've been focusing on these
what are called receptors as the source
of identity I realize no it's what's
activating what's typing is the identity
and then it hit me and said oh my God my
identity is not in the cell my identity
is a signal coming from the environment
typing in the keyboard and then I said
oh and the first thing that hit me was
I can't die I'm not even in here
and that instant of fear which all of us
have in our deepest bottom belief system
is a fear of more mortality
and when that moment of like I can't die
not as a devotional belief it had
nothing to do with that it was just a
mechanism I said oh my God I can't die
I tell you the same thing happened with
Savages me
tears started rolling down my face and
this Joy was an ache in my heart that
I've never experienced before I spent 40
years in my head that's how I became an
academician and a research scientist and
when this moment hit it was my heart
that blew open I referred to it as a
heart orgasm and
and that was the first time I
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence and what happened was
I was overwhelmed first with the fact
that I was not spiritual at 1 59 a.m and
at 2 A.M I was 100 spiritual you have a
very close friend you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent and at some point you
see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
Bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill because Bill's the first guy that
says how could you compare me to my dad
and everyone laughs because they're
familiar but I say no there's two very
profound points from that one story and
profound Point number one everybody else
can see that bill behaves like his dad
he got his programming from his dad it's
only Bill who doesn't see it and
profound Point number two we're all
built because all of us got programming
and all of us operate with these
programs and we don't even see we're
doing that we even when told we're doing
it will deny that we do these behaviors
because we don't even see what we're
doing that's why it's called
subconscious below conscious when I
first started talking about it it was
from an academic conscious point of view
this is what I learned but my
subconscious programs are still exactly
the same so well I had this wonderful
knowledge my life still wasn't anything
I wanted to to brag about it because it
wasn't and and as you know that old
gamer who would you like to be and I
could think of anybody I'd rather be
than me And yet when I started to apply
the new science and rewrite the
subconscious so it supported me rather
than the programs of limitation or
disempowerment that we get from our
parents and our community as children
which almost all of us get when I put in
the new programs all of a sudden I
started to find my goodness my life
completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life I was healthier I haven't been to a
doctor in 20 years I I don't need that I
don't take any of their drugs why
because most of the illness is just from
the stress of not living in Harmony and
when you learn to to get rid of the
limiting programs that we got as
children and put in programs that
support you guess what then all of a
sudden the place turns into heaven uh
and it's interesting to people I tell
people will you create your own life and
then they look around and go I don't
want responsibility for this but I say
well you didn't know you were creating
with these unconscious beliefs and and
yet then I tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels in love I said go
back to that time when you first fell in
love let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah I was I was healthy
as anything I said you have energy I
said oh I had so much energy made love
for days in a row without even eating
and I go yeah and I go uh and how was
life for you it was so exciting I
couldn't wait for the next day so I said
in this little period that you you know
that I refer to as a honeymoon I say
wasn't life like heaven on Earth and
they go well yeah and I go you know that
was not an accident that was an actual
creation and you say but what was
different that made life uh uh so heaven
on Earth during love and the answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date I say
especially the women I say how long did
it take to get dressed and they say well
it was 15 minutes and I was out of the
house and then I say now tonight you're
going to go on a date with this person
who has just rocked your world and I
said how long does it take you to get
dressed it's like my God it may take an
hour or two and I said yesterday 15
minutes today an hour or two what's the
difference yesterday I got dressed by
habit because I get dressed every day
but tonight I am looking in the mirror
meaning I am self-conscious I am making
sure that I represent myself to be the
fully the best individual I can be and
when both parties are not relying on the
habit and both of them are saying I'm
creating the best I can be they're
living in the moment of them now they're
being very mindful they're being very
present and guess what
heaven on Earth is created many people
may think well hold on a second so I can
take five minutes and I can totally
change my life and that's all I need and
I think that's a really a wonderful
possibility but the probability is this
are you going to hit the right statement
that is the one that you need to change
your life okay uh let's say someone's
overweight and they say in their mind I
I am you know a weight a number they
like I am 125 pounds and you're not uh
and I say uh so I want to change my
weight and I put a program in I'm going
to lose weight
and I go about well wait that extra
poundage uh that might be due to
protection okay what do you mean I say
if I was as an as a young person was
abused then the Consciousness is if I'm
a heavy person they won't bother me
anymore and so the weight isn't due to
just eating food the weight is due to
I'm safer being heavy than I am I say
well if you want to change your weight
you can talk about the weight all you
want but until you adjust the problem
from the the fear uh you know that I'm
going to be abused that's where the
problem came from it didn't come from
eating food over here so I said yeah
well you can change beliefs uh sometimes
I like to give a visual a matter of fact
I visualize a big spider web which has
like circles and then lines coming out
you know like a web okay and so there
are links as you go around there's also
anchors where the web is anchored at a
couple places and I go each belief is
like a link
and that spider weapon you can do one
link on another link and another link
that really changes by your web but if
you do a belief that is an anchor and
you change the anchor belief and that
anchor lets go the web will collapse
that's possible right and the point is
this sometimes a police statement knocks
out a link
but when you really hit it just right
you knock out a support and when you
knock out a major support the whole web
collapses instead of just a link at a
time which could take it down but it's
much harder in our mind we start to
realize that we're concerned we're
afraid we don't have enough I'm not safe
I'm not secure and I say oh these
thoughts I was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and I go yes
this is really true I said well how can
I tell you what your thoughts are in a
sense that can I read your thoughts and
I say yes you know I could put wires on
your head and it's called
electroencephalograph and I could read
your brain activity and I go oh great I
can see this brain activity
I want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
Magneto encephalograph I say what's
unique about that I say it reads your
brain I say yeah but so does EEG I say
yeah but EEG put the wires on the head
and you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what I'm reading and I
said what's different about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I say
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there in the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the peace and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified each of us
has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your Energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the soul governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm so what
was Einstein saying it's the energy in
the field that shapes the physical
experience of our lives and if enough of
us collectively have an energy that's
coherent and strong and we broadcast the
belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts and if we want to change
reality it can change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and Assad Vegeta has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end we all have
approximately 50 trillion cells in our
body and these cells are all
self-sufficient they have their own
memory they have their immune immune
system and in fact you're also going to
say that for 2.75 billion years there
was only one celled organisms alive on
the planet yeah and the nature is as the
Single Cell evolved to be the most
intelligent and could be it ran into a
physical limitation because intelligence
is physically tied up with the membrane
or skin of the cell you can only have so
much membrane so Evolution apparently
stopped it was like two and a half
billion years just a single cell
organism then it said well how can you
have more Evolution the answer is cells
decided to come together in community
because when cells come into Community
they share awareness so there's more
awareness with 10 cells than there is
with one cell and there's more awareness
with a million or a billion or a
trillion so when you look at a human
being while we see ourselves as single
entities the truth is we are made out of
50 trillion amoeba like cells and so our
bodies this giant community and what
makes it very exciting as you mentioned
is well in my own work with cloning
cells I can take a cell out of your body
and could live outside of you why it has
its own intelligence it has essentially
every function in your body is present
in a Cell so my seven-year-old Vision
manifests to be true when I got older to
realize cells are Miniature people and
then you say well what about happens in
the human body and I go this is where
the issue comes in is because you have
50 trillion cells living in community
but your mind is the government
when a government works in harmony with
the people then the people thrive and
the community is is in good health and
grows but when a government is not
really supportive or not working in in
harmony with a community then the
government can cause the the the nature
of that Community to fall apart and even
lead to to the end of the community well
that's what we're finding out our mind
is the government and when we entertain
Harmony and and the right living and
balance with nature and with each other
then we provide our 50 trillion cells
with very life-supporting information
and chemistry so Harmony means
giving the body good food yes not being
stressed out absolutely living in a in a
happy environment yes basically it says
uh it's as I said when I had my petri
dish of cells if I put it from a healthy
environment to a bad environment the
cells got sick but you didn't have to
give them drugs uh but all you did is
take the the dish from the bad
environment and put it in a good
environment and the joke which I like to
tell people is well this happens in the
plastic petri dishes but guess what we
are skin covered petri dishes underneath
our skin is 50 trillion cells living in
addition the culture medium is the blood
and so when I change the culture meaning
in a plastic dish I changed the fate of
the cells and I say well then what
controls the culture medium my blood the
chemistry and the answer is my thoughts
influence my brain and the Brain
releases chemistry that matches my
thoughts so when I'm in stress or I'm
afraid of the world I release different
chemistry into the blood than if I open
up my eyes and I find myself in love I
release completely different chemistry
and it's like well all I have to ask in
individual is how do you feel when
you're in total love or how do you feel
when you're in fear and the answer is
well I feel totally different guess what
all the cells are bathed in that
chemistry and so the the feeling of Love
produces totally different chemistry in
the blood chemistry that supports growth
and healing of the body and supports the
immune system and in contrast when we
perceive reasons to be afraid and we
release stress hormones into our body we
actually shut off the growth mechanisms
and the immune system to serve to save
the energy why because if you believe
you're going to have to run from that
lion you want all the energy available
to run from a line so when a person is
in stress they allocate their energy
reserves for fight or flight but take it
at the expense of the health of the
system the immune part of the system and
so the more stress you're under the more
bad chemistry in a sense of not
supporting you you that you experience
uh and and it was a very important point
in our Evolution stress or fear was not
the Mainstay of Life the Mainstay of
life was to be happy and live in the
harmony of the environment every now and
then a saber-toothed tiger would come
okay now it's time to be stressed out
now it's time to run but the point is
once you escape from the saber-toothed
tiger in the old days and it's like oh
back to health and Harmony and I said
what about today's world today's world
is 24 7 run from the tiger and this is
not biologically sustainable because uh
the chemistry of protection uh contrasts
with the chemistry of growth
you in here doc
hello
doc yeah it's Marty where are you
oh okay yeah yeah I'll be right there
[Music]
doc where are you
hey Doc let me hear this pouring rain
out here just wait just wait two more
seconds
oh oh no oh
Marty Marty Marty we gotta Get Back to
the Future what happened to the DeLorean
oh I couldn't keep up with the payments
during the pandemic but hey this is a
good baby
[Music]
all right all right
Marty Marty we have to go back to the
future right now Doc
Victor seems very uncertain I don't
think we should be going to the Future
right now you're not thinking fourth
dimensionally get in the car I'll
explain it to you when we get there all
right
[Music]
foreign
doc where are we when are we Marty just
look at the inboard monitor down there
and what you can see is we are in
between time we're moving from an old
civilization and we're moving through
time into the future of a new
civilization
wow this looks pretty chaotic and random
is that normal well actually it's not
random and you're right it is chaotic
because chaotic has pattern even though
you can't see it and if you want to know
what the pattern is look the old
civilization is coming down and as it's
coming down the pieces are forming a new
civilization that is rising up and we
are now in the middle so it's not random
so this is all just a big illusion well
it is an illusion because once you think
the world is made out of matter and
energy that's a false understanding but
now quantum physics revealed there is no
separation of matter and energy atoms
which make up matter are energy so
everything is an illusion reality is an
illusion albeit a persistent one
so you're telling me that the future
changes depending on the field that we
have intentions for well absolutely the
reason is this because as the planet
moves through the solar system and the
universe the energy surrounding this
planet changes that's the field and when
the field changes the matter changes so
we're in a process of evolution moving
from an old structure into a new
sustainable world to understand what I'm
talking about Marty look at the inboard
monitor there I can show you about the
signs called cymatics that's the science
of how vibration and energy and feel
shapes matter
as you can see how it works you sprinkle
particles on a metal plate and then when
you play a vibration and energy field
through that plate the vibration causes
the particles to jump around and form a
pattern but when you change the
vibration the old pattern falls apart
and simultaneously a new pattern is
emerging this is exactly where we are
today in Planet Earth
wow doc that is sick
sick Marty I don't know what you kids
are talking about everything is sick no
we're moving into the future where
everything is health and Harmony and
love hold on Marty
maybe we should start focusing on what
we want and not focusing on on what
we're afraid of and that's where the
bigger problem comes from at this moment
and recognizing this has been brought up
before we're birthing a new civilization
and recognize this birth is always
associated with some pain a little blood
uh as the process unfolds and so when we
look at the world and we say it's
struggling right now I say yeah this is
a birthing pain that we're experiencing
and you have a choice you could focus on
the pain where you could focus on the
baby and that's coming here and think
about it know how much of a woman is
screaming the moment before the baby
comes out uh the moment the baby's out
there's no more pain anymore it's gone
because the Love Has covered everything
you know and this is what we're at now
this is where we are we are creating
something new let's not focus on on the
Pain part because it's the birth that is
the most amazing experiencing uh
experience that is coming to this planet
right now
all of us are uh on the threshold of
seeing a new civilization this is an
amazing time
in human civilization we're here to
observe an evolutionary event unfolding
immediately in front of your eyes but
we're more than observers we're
participants
and that's what this whole uplift
program is all about each one of us is
contributing a vibration a Consciousness
a thought
and building something so beautiful
that heaven on Earth is actually a way
of life the new science that is just
coming into the Forefront of our world
today is is something called epigenetic
control what I was teaching was genetic
control controlled by genes the new
science which is now coming around is
called epigenetic control and what that
means in the you understand the prefix
Epi means above so you say epidermis
that means the layer above the dermis
skin if I say epigenetic control
literally it says control above the
genes and this is the new science and
why is it profound
because when you teach genetic control
you teach victimization you didn't pick
the genes as far as we know the genes
control your traits you can't change the
genes so you become victimized by your
heredity and the new science epigenetic
control reveals how your response to the
environment as you change your response
to the environment you change the fate
of yourselves just like in the petri
dish that makes you a master because
you're the one that has the opportunity
to change your perception and response
so therefore you're the one that
controls your genes if you want another
amazing Bruce Lipton video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there